[Music]
the question at this point is how many
days in a row can I talk about Shawn
Mendes and Camilla Kibeho a limit does
not exist but also he dropped her and
guys the look on his face as it was
happening is priceless
this all happened while they were
rehearsing for their senior itzá music
video and the aftermath is adorable
yeah I see the way you grazed her arm
with your hand Shawn the dancing was
actually amazing up until that point
[Applause]
[Music]
I really just can't get over his face
that part turned into this scene in the
video though now this isn't the only
behind the scenes we got Sean actually
uploaded a whole video worth of bonus
footage and for that we say thank you
here are some of the best parts right
here
Thank You Camilla for pointing out the
dog pee Sean gets camera ready with his
guitar in hand I feel good I feel do
this dance the first scene is the
dancing the way they pump each other up
bond set is the best Sean giving ideas I
don't know if I'm taking my shirt off or
not or if she should do that and I think
I should take if I should like get it
easier shirt to take off and Camila
laughing during this she was amazing
like super talented his songwriter like
I've never worked at the actual
songwriter who I clicked with as well as
to her she's amazing he's amazing they
are hilarious together I cannot wait for
part two of the behind the scenes but
what part of this video did you like the
most
let me know and for all the latest on
Sean and Camila keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Music]